最近ずっと静岡に入れて平和な日常をくれていたんですけど明日からしばらく東京にい
ます
これぐらいただカメラでも割れるは言え
まずはれそうなんでも実際今季で流れるはいきます
ああああああ
るっ
これじゃあ外れ社長ですね図形勢の皆さんがお受験お疲れさまでやってる人もいるかも
しれないそうになってきたこと言えないんですけど来年ず厳選の方は側ソロ本ゴス入れ
て頃かな
春から中3高山になる人だぜそろそろもうやっちゃっていいんじゃないですかね
というわけでそろそろ春休みの方もいると思いますねやっぱ新学期はご新規一転して
文房具欲しくなるわけでござい
いますよ今回は
すごいと思うはいこちらはいい
うほレンズをレンズなのノック1回で芯が出続ける会館で号発行のがすごい
メカニカル感が凄い計算されてるのかよやめてサビサすぎてみんな忘れてるかもしれ
ないけどね文房具たくなった正確に言えばシャーペンなんですけど食べが好きすぎて
定期的にシャーペンの紹介したんですけども最近あんまりやってなかったんですけども
これはちょっと
すごいなと思って買ってみました値段だよ値段値段でた取れずネロのまず値段化する
かって気がする
なんでネロって言うだろうね8個いいなめっちゃかっこいいじゃんこれ
商品の特徴あなたのぺんてる最高峰のさっペースローナーに崔候補なの
いやなるほどなるほどするそう同窓0ねあーなるほどねシンジどうだ式のやばいじゃん
これはすごいん
うわぁ
プール la は色々調べてみたんですけれども敏輝さんのんか
集大成感があるなぁこれはちょっと開けていきましょうかあ下段でたんだなぁなるほど
けどこれ
30円ですすぎな3000のシャーペンでなかなかそうないと思いますよ大概のラミー
とかちょっと開けていきましょう
怖いよ開けます
[音楽]
なんか実は結構スッキリ知ってるが
プリ扱い説明書が岸リトルかと思った大
レンズゼロの説明書ですねもうしっかり書いてありますねオレンジネロ真意を出さない
出かけシャープペンシルですをレンズって言うのは芯が折れないシャープペンするでし
た
で今回ほどをレンズネロってなにかといいますと自動戦だし機構がついているらしいの
で簡単
言えばこれ1本で芯が折れずに自動死んだし機構が付いているので1回シニア例えば
無限でかけ続けるらしい
つまりシャー芯が折れなくて1回ノックするだけで園に書き続けられるもう最強の
サーフィンらしいです
ただネオレンズはね深な音振動太さかねーーて課税というさんなんですよね
今まあその分そもそもとがらなくていいって言ってくるとた本だよ
気になるべきであった機能をしよほどすることによってネックしているという利点は
ありますだからあまり気にしなくても細いでしょうねそうそうも見たらこんな感じで
ございますやはりせず用シャーペンよりのパのちょっと出てる感じでペン先が見えて
くるはずです
大 ok な
やっぱ黒っていいよね雨ロッテ黒って揺らせてイタリア語でこれすごいなぁまぁ実際に
書いてみるとわかるんですけども
ちょっとまとめ勝ってください値段なりの多分あるんだと思いますオレンジだから芯が
折れない増え心が自動でええねんで続ける彼らのオープンしていますそして低重心なで
疲れないという最強のサーフへなぜでございます参加学生が終わってからそんなに
しゃべる持つことな
んですけど何でたまに書いたりするんですよ
1回書いてみましょうこれやと思うた目線が出すぎですね
もうね多分見えないぐらいでいいんですよこれがちょっと出てるだけで多分書き続け
られるはずが書いてみましょうか
ええええええ
もうわぁまあまあう
待ってプロズ a 2掛けるってことすごいよこれ
というわけでちょっと書いてみたんですけども木正直言いますと0.5の写真信者なん
ですよ
結構太めでぐったり人間なんですけども重心が低くてないと個人的なスマッシュな感覚
を感じることができました
はこれや分いやこれちゃん全部のカツはありますって
まあもうやばいは何だろう東大9気がしてきただけでちょっと書いてみたんですけども
すごいぞ
持ってを振っちゃってもだぜに3000円だなっていう感じはしましたあのスマッシュ
とか本当に最高のシャーペンだったしオレンジ欲しい俺なくてもいいと思ったしその
いいっところだけは取り上げて作ったあーなんか醜態点というか左入ってるなって感じ
た逸品でした
作っ
いうのがお水のクローンやっぱシャーペンって結局でマートをいるよ頭に赤くだった
なおすっけ黒だったなぁみちゃんですけど結局黒が一番かっこいいと思ってますっても
と黒いシャーペンの音が入ったらどうせでは女の子のみんなこれでしょ
やろいやーかっこいいなぜてくれたら8新学期始まると思いますそして春休みの宿題も
あると思いますそして来年よ付んだよってきた立ち絵もスタートちっちゃ
良いと思います新しい学校に入学した皆さんスタートダッシュが肝心やで
いや本当にいいシャーペンでした3000の価値は僕は正直あると思います
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ